NICERY TO
THE LONG SHOT FROM THE CORNER.
>> IT
A LITTLE GIVEN
THE SHORT SIDE..PERFECT SAME.
NO CANADIAN PLAYERS THERE.
THERE'S NO WHERE  SCORES!
BEN CHIAROT KEEPS IT IN AND
THEY ATTACK OFFENSIVELY.
HERE'S THE  TURNOVER.
HE HAD THIS ONE
AROUND.
THEY SEND IT AH TERRITORY
RYAN HAS ANOT
WE WILL SEE WHAT WE GET IN
SHOT IN FRONT PICK WE HAVE TO G
HE HAS TWO DEFENDERS MOVING
FORWARD TO POWER PLAY
SEASON.
AND ITS KELLER.
HE SHOOTS. TO MAKE THE PASS
TO THE MIDDLE AND THEN HE GETS
THE PASS RIGHT BACK AND
REDIRECTING THE SHOTS OF THE
POWER PLAY GOAL HAS THE
CANADIANS WITH NOW
WHICH GIVES MORE TIME FOR
JONATHAN DROUIN RIGHT HERE.
HE DOESN'T GET ALL OF THIS SHTH
AND THEIR YOU SEE GLAD WITH THE
POTENTIAL
GOSTISBEHERE  THERE.
KELLER TAKES A SHOT.OPENS UP TH
CAN SEE BOYD READY FOR KELLER T
STICK CANDLE WHICHIN FRONT.
THE TIME AND SPACE AND YOU SEE